when banks were caught rigging the
London interbank lending rate or libor
came the realization that there needed
to be more transparency over how the
rate of loans mortgages and financial
transactions are fixed by banks after
billions and fines being slapped on the
big culprits over to the Parliament
where me pease put new EU wide rules to
a vote the basic thing is that we make a
distinction between critical and
non-critical benchmarks because we all
we don't want to cause unnecessary
administrative burden so for the ones
that are not critical we don't have the
same requirements something will fall
within the ambit of a critical benchmark
if the rate at which it is valued is
over 500 billion euros which then has
the ability to impact market stability
but for some the distinction has
weakened regulation now all benchmarks
which are based on regulated data which
applies to most financial benchmarks
cannot be critical benchmarks and
therefore are falling out of strong
European supervision and this means
basically that on libor and other
important benchmarks no strong European
action will be done whether the
definition of critical benchmarks will
find itself undergoing a transformation
all depends on when the draft law goes
to a vote at the plenary
you